match these angles with their measures
there should be one angle in each
category of 30 degrees six degrees 90
degrees and 180 degrees so there's a few
that are very easy to spot out this
angle right over here it's it makes a
complete line so this is clearly 180
degrees so this one's 180 degrees the
other one that might jump out at you is
this one right over here this is clearly
a right angle or a 90-degree angle right
over here so this is 90 degrees and so
we have to think which of these is 30
and which is 60 degrees well just by
comparing it that way you know that the
one that opens out more is going to be
60 degrees and the one that opens out
less is going to be 30 degrees and you
can see that this the opening here is
half the size of the opening right over
here so it makes sense that this is 30
this is 60 and also makes sense that
this angle is one-third the measure of
this angle right over here that this is
90 degrees and then if you were to
double this then this this part of the
angle would go all the way out and you
would get to 180 degrees so let's check
our answer make sure we we actually got
this one right let's do one more just
for fun which of these angles has a
measure of 60 degrees so there's a
couple that we can immediately rule out
this angle here is clearly more than 90
degrees it's an obtuse angle this angle
here is 180 degrees so we're gonna have
to pick between these two and we can
assume that these are all at scale so if
we know that a right angle would have
this line straight up and down this
looks like it's two-thirds of the way
there so I would go with this one right
over there now you might say well what
about this one
well this one looks like it's about a
third of a right angle if we were to do
two thirds then three thirds it looks
like we would get to a right angle so
this one looks much closer to 30 degrees
so which of these angles has a measure
of 60 that one right over there you can
immediately rule out that one and that
one and then these take a little bit
closer inspection